hi and welcome to the big epic
engineering channel where we look at
very big buildings today's subject is
egypt's new administrative capital a
futuristic metropolis built from scratch
by the egyptian government we've all
heard of big mega projects before but
what makes this one truly stand out is
its sheer bigness so what does this big
epic project entail the middle east's
biggest mega cathedral two big mega
mosques one of them egypt's biggest the
world's biggest skyscraper and two dozen
more the capital park twice as big as
central park to promote social
interactions there's also the world's
biggest military headquarters aka the
octagon a whole new district for all the
egyptian ministries a
smaller district with all the important
institutions a big area called people
square with the world's biggest flagpole
and two theaters and a big 20 lane road
for military parades plus a monument as
big as a whole neighborhood two new
parliament buildings a big new
presidential palace the biggest
automated monorail system in the world
and to top it all off an american-style
suburb so this is egypt's new
administrative capital in a nutshell
wait what's that this project is
pointless at best and incredibly harmful
at worst
but but it's big what the sheer size and
scope of a project alone does not make
it good
but but but big buildings look at how
big they are bigly big they're so big
huh oh no what is this
oh no
so much for algorithm generated urbanism
content looks like we'll have to do this
the old-fashioned way after all
so egypt's new administrative capital it
is a truly enormous undertaking by the
egyptian government its scale only
surpassed by its sheer stupidity when
discussing this project we have to ask
ourselves what is wrong with a dictator
building a colossal vanity project in
the desert from scratch in a country
where the minimum wage is 127 dollars
per month let's find out the new
administrative capital was already a
dumb idea but with a few bold steps
they've managed to reach unprecedented
levels of idiosa where in my opinion
they have managed to surpass even dubai
i'm not exaggerating like the saying
goes smooth brain dictator plus
construction project equals dumb [ __ ]
and oh boy do we have some of that here
courtesy of desert ciao as the name
shows the project itself is meant to
create an all-new administrative center
for the egyptian government moving them
out of central cairo this isn't the
first of such projects the new
administrative capital is right next to
new cairo city built by the previous
dictator which is a 500 square kilometer
gentrified car-centric urban heliscape
so egypt's current dictator abdel fattah
khan sisi took a look at new cairo city
and thought yeah we can build something
bigger than that and so the new
administrative capital was born so let's
go over the major parts of this project
to explain why exactly they're stupid or
in this case outright evil first the
obvious stuff both the world's tallest
flagpole and the world's tallest
skyscraper because [ __ ] it why not the
flagpole is of course nothing more than
nationalistic dick waving as for the
skyscraper if you've been watching my
content before you know why it's a bad
idea especially in the desert to
reiterate there's just no good reason to
build skyscrapers the higher your build
the more engineering problems you have
to solve and the more expensive things
get even if you're after the largest
possible floor space you're still better
off with mid-rises in my video about
skyscrapers i've illustrated how the
burj khalifa the world's current tallest
skyscraper could be outdone in terms of
floor space by building five midwise
comey blocks on its footprint otherwise
skyscrapers waste a ton of energy by
virtue of being giant hunks of glass and
steel their price per square meter is
significantly higher than mid rises and
they alienate people by complicating
access to public spaces such as sparks
and so on now there are some edge cases
where you have no choice but to build
skyscrapers on very small footprints and
very close to each other because you
simply have no available space but as
you can see for the new administrative
capital space isn't really an issue by
virtue of it being out in the open
desert so why does egypt want to build
the world's tallest skyscraper plus two
dozen more the same reason as the
flagpole i.e as part of the
international dictator's deck waving
contest dictators really do love
building big dumb things for no reason
germania is a good example which was
hitler's renewal plan for berlin that
was mostly about redoing the city centre
with overly large buildings one of them
was a triumphal arch scene in the middle
which was supposed to be so large the
paris arc de triomphe would have fit
under it hitler also envisioned a square
the grand plaza which was supposed to be
350 000 square meters here it is
overlaid on inner city prague today's
dictators prefer skyscrapers though
because that's what's trendy nowadays
hence the new administrative capital
containing two dozen of them one of
which is to be the world's tallest as
mentioned between those skyscrapers and
what appears to be two 10-lane urban
freeways lies the capital park now
called the green river park the purpose
of which is providing shade and
encouraging social activities great i
love it when my parks provide shade and
encourage social activities corporate
bullet points aside the real purpose of
this park is to be six times the size of
central park that's it and considering
you're creating a 2509 hectare lawn in
the middle of the desert the water
consumption of this thing will be beyond
belief which i'm sure will do wonders
for stability in the region ethiopia's
kansas belly for launching a water war
will be egyptians watering their lawn
however skyscrapers flagpoles and
disturbingly large parks are the least
of our worries here if you can believe
that let's take a look at the
residential areas envisioned in the
project in terms of urbanism they're
complete bonkers the most obvious
problem is that most areas are
completely car centric that means blocks
of residential buildings divided by
large roads and six to eight lane
arterial roads with minimal to no public
transit the worst offender might be la
vista city here which is an american
style suburb in the desert next to a
freeway bordered by an arterial road now
there are plenty of videos out there
detailing why american suburbs are the
worst thing you can build for now let's
just say they isolate people socially
force you to be core dependent services
and amenities are far away it's near
impossible to have good public transit
due to low density it's much more
expensive to drag out utilities to each
house and so on long story short
american suburbs are an urbanism
nightmare back to egypt there's the r5
residential area a district with fake
french architecture you know how
primitive oligarchs and their children
love ultra expensive french luxury goods
the r5 is basically that just on a whole
other level by the way in the new
administrative capital the only
meaningful public transit will be a
high-speed rail line and that's good but
they're also building a monorail line
because of course they are this one will
cost 4.5 billion dollars but you already
have the metro it's right there why not
just extend that why create a whole new
system which has significantly lower
capacity than a metro line this whole
new standalone rich people's
transportation neatly separated from
public transit for the poor's what a
strange coincidence huh aside from the
monorail the whole new administrative
capital is of course completely car
centric here we have a render of the r3
residential area which looks like
something a six-year-old will build in
simcity 3000 with the money cheat on
it's all urban freeways after all public
transit is for the unwashed masses not
the elite yes if you thought all this
was being built for the ordinary
egyptian then i got some prime real
estate to sell you out in the sahara
according to this reuters article some
22 million egyptians live in slums to
this day which is a quarter of the
country's entire population is anything
being done to better their situation in
four years the government managed to
relocate 750 000 people from slums to
social housing at this rate assuming
islam's population won't grow clearing
all of them will take 117 years well to
be fair the egyptian government has more
important things to spend on the world's
tallest flagpole isn't going to build
itself also low-income families from
slums are often relocated into car
centric areas which severely restrict
their mobility these areas are also
heavily segregated from higher income
neighborhoods and risk becoming slums
all over again the issue here is of
course the egyptian government's
socio-economic priorities best
illustrated by this picture of an urban
freeway being built in cairo
approximately one meter away from
people's windows otherwise a very
telling example is the fate of the
so-called mospero triangle which is a
slum area not far from doctrine square
in central cairo home to some 18 000
people in the 90s under the previous
dictator the authorities forbade doing
any repair work on the houses under a
threat of heavy fines soon enough
buildings started collapsing often with
their inhabitants inside thus forced
evictions began due to quote-unquote
unsafe conditions this didn't really
stop until the 2011 egyptian revolution
where the most pair of islam became a
hotbed for revolutionaries providing
essential support for those protesting
on tahrir square in the end egypt of
course ended up with a different
dictator who decided to finish the job
and had the entire area bulldozed 18 000
people were forcibly evicted so that a
gentrified high-rise area can be built
there hashtag gas the poor and the new
administrative capital is not much
different in terms of social value all
this is being built not for the ordinary
person but for the ruling class and
their allies it is in large part meant
to solidify the dictatorship by
insulating the leadership from common
people it's significantly harder to
overthrow your government when the
parliament is 12 hours away a foot in
the desert and you have to break through
20 military checkpoints to get there the
other half of the story is of course
money within the company responsible for
the project the military happens to be a
majority shareholder that company is
also responsible for selling and
operating all that ultra expensive
property left empty by moving the
government to the district they're
building the egyptian military really is
a state within a state the dictatorship
thus the country is held together by
them they are the true egyptian ruling
class the ultimate symbol of this is the
most ludicrous element of the project
the octagon the octagon is the egyptian
military's new headquarters in terms of
military power egypt is on par with
italy but apparently they need an hq
eight times the size of the pentagon
which makes it you guessed it the
largest in the world but the octagon is
more than just a military headquarters
around this abomination there are
housing complexes public services
amenities and so on making the octagon a
city within a city and this is
deliberate of course what we have here
is a brand new castle for the egyptian
military ruling class so in the new
administrative capital we have district
for the egyptian upper class the
political class a castle for the
military ruling class a whole bunch of
world's largest acts [ __ ] projects
and a new palace for the dictator all
neatly separated from the riffraff
meanwhile kairo's problems are numerous
and severe aside from the aforementioned
slums and general poverty urban planning
in cairo is either non-existent or
beyond insane according to tomtom it is
the 30th most congested city on the
planet no wonder traffic management as a
concept doesn't exist in kaido traffic
rules are a suggestion and nobody will
check compliance crossing the road as a
pedestrian is an incredibly risky
maneuver and not looking around
beforehand is practically suicide also
did you know that cairo the 7th largest
metro area on the planet barely operates
any traffic lights vehicle safety is a
foreign concept on the picture you can
see an old five-seater soviet car packed
absolutely for with children because
this is a school bus yep according to
the who every year approximately 12 000
egyptians die in road accidents a number
both insane and unsurprising meanwhile
public transit is woefully
underdeveloped for example the greater
cairo area of 20.9 million people is
currently served by two and a half metro
lines in contrast the paris metro area
of 15 million people is served by 16
metro lines and five major suburban rail
lines there are some tram lines in cairo
but the ones in the center were
demolished long ago and what remains is
more of a rolling museum than a transit
system beyond these there's a municipal
bus system that exists and below that
the most crucial part of cairo's public
transit minibuses the website discover
discomfort in their article described
them like so riding a microbus takes
practice it's hard to get the right one
as you have to master certain hand
signals and codes to be able to discern
which to get eg a fist takes us to our
neighborhood doki it's hard to sit in
the right place in a micro bus judging
where isn't too close to the front so
you're in everyone's way and where isn't
too deep so everyone is in yours and
it's hard to get off knowing what to
yell and when and diving off in the 10
seconds you have to make it happen as
you can see this is not a serious public
transit system more like a half-baked
haphazard mess that kinda sort of
functions because it has to just like
the city of cairo as a whole and the
leadership does not care instead they're
spending money on the aforementioned
monorail between the new administrative
capital and east cairo costing 4.5
billion dollars imagine what could have
been done inside kaido for that kind of
money but instead they opted for a shiny
gadget bomb [ __ ] project because
spending money on kairo would serve the
poor while the monreal will serve the
upper classes other parts of this
project are just further insult to
injury the unknown soldier monument is
just a handout to military adjacent real
estate companies also got a lot of giant
ant symbols all around it's about as
subtle as the character design in jojo's
bizarre adventure and here i'd like to
take a brief aside and voice my overall
disappointment with quote-unquote
urbanism content on youtube i hate how
many content creators almost never
examine any project beyond look how big
it is it is my belief that urbanism
related content should be more than just
bamboozling people with big numbers and
cgi you should look at whom the project
is built for how it affects people i.e
its socioeconomic costs and benefits in
lieu of that you're just jingling keys
in front of a bunch of babies and also
get 100 million views in the process in
general if you can replace your audio
with a donald trump level
self-aggrandizing [ __ ] speech with
stock music and not lose much of the
information value you might want to
rethink your video look i know
skyscrapers i love skyscrapers many of
my best friends are skyscrapers this is
the best skyscraper ever constructed
ever billions and billions of square
feet most tall in the world bigly built
big business activities very big
business at the end of the day urbanism
is more than just building some big
shiny buildings it's the built
environment we humans are meant to
inhabit a building on its own is just a
heap of bricks metal and concrete its
intended purpose the kind of people it
will serve its location accessibility
those are what make a building worth
talking about but very often these
quote-unquote urbanism channels only
focus on the physical object and some
easy remarkable numbers nothing more
sure the new administrative capital
looks impressive lots of big buildings
big big buildings but that alone tells
us nothing about what it really is a
dictator's [ __ ] penalty project at
the expense of tens of millions were
forced to live in poverty for decades to
come but it didn't have to be this way
egyptian authorities could have put
their traffic management in order create
a workable municipal bus system build
new metro lines more affordable housing
and they could have improved cairo's
chaotic urban planning instead they
chose to build a 40 billion dollar
monument to hubris and sociopathy
brainlessly celebrated by people who
ought to know better welcome to egypt's
new administrative capital where
buildings are big and brains are smooth
following my desert megaproject
tradition i'll leave you with a poem
this one is titled ozimendis by perseve
i met a traveler from an antique land
who said do vast and trunkless legs of
stone stand in the desert near them on
the sand half sonky shattered visage
lies whose frown and wrinkled lip and
sneer of cold command tell that its
sculptor well those passions read which
yet survive stemmed on these lifeless
things the hand that mocked them and the
heart that fed and on the pedestal these
words appear my name is ozymendis king
of kings look on my works ye mighty and
despair nothing beside remains from the
decay of that colossal wreck boundless
and bare the lowland level sands stretch
far away